[Music]
with I know I know I wish I was in there
this
to first
question how do you go about putting
your team together when you're
producing that's a good question I mean
I think that every project requires its
own set of personalities and I always
say film making is easy it's the
personalities that are difficult and it
it starts with the director and I think
the team is built around that energy and
that creativity and that
Vision but it helps know a lot of
people
how
[Music]
do it definitely has a lot of meaning
for me I'm really proud for the Chinese
American Community I hope that it sets
an example for other Chinese Americans
that it's okay not to be a lawyer or you
know a businessman or a doctor it's okay
to make independent films
you can win $225,000 too um but if
anything I just hope that it it shows
other Chinese Americans that it's okay
to work in film and
television any other questions you talk
more about your next the next project is
a film called Jack and Diane it's by the
director of the exploding girl and it's
about two girls who fall in love one
somewhere in New York City one of them
turns into your werewolf as an
expression of her love and sexuality
that's fin question yes how a project
comes to your hands and you fall in love
with it it's a work with it how you fall
in love with a project how do I how do
how project gets to you and you fall in
love with it you want to do it AB I mean
I spend a minimum of five years on a
project so I'm exploting girl on Santa
Mesa whatever the film is so I have to I
know that I'm going to you know
essentially be married to the director
for that time and I have to I have to
feel that no matter what this film has
to be made because if I don't feel that
way we're never going to make it through
to the
end thank you thank
you